[Music]
imagine walking down the sidewalk and
running into these creatures check those
out that gerbil you see there in the
robot suit is a 3d chalk sketch from the
imagination of david zinn he's a popular
street artist behind creations like
these all made from chalk and charcoal
his mission is to show you that you
don't need fancy supplies to make art he
gets paid to create his art commissions
worldwide from a village square in
germany to the streets of laguna beach
california zinn showed us how he brings
his ideas to life
what do you look for what's a canvas on
the street oh anything to most people
this might look like an ordinary street
but to david zinn it offers endless
possibilities there's strange little
posts in the ground sometimes no one can
tell me why they're there so they might
be there for this person you know
just for you to start drawing yeah maybe
who knows for more than 20 years the
michigan native worked as a freelance
commercial artist until a box of
colorful sidewalk chalk convinced him to
leave his day job that is a squirrel's
tail
the 52 year old now creates whimsical 3d
drawings right on the spot using
everything from manhole covers to weeds
and street cracks as his inspiration a
few minutes ago this was just a patch
and it wanted to be a hole in the ground
yeah i see the hole in the ground yeah
so it's working that's it
why did you decide to start doing art
with chalk of all things
the honest answer is that i was looking
for an excuse to be outside on a nice
day that was how it started that's it um
yeah we all seem to have chalk in our
house it's just very easy to come by
which is one of the things that i think
makes it a good thing to make art with
because it's not precious philomena the
flying pig is just one of the characters
that often pops up there was
and is one perfectly flat small brick
right here that is perfect for a pig
head so that's where the pig had to go
and this is where the window ledge had
to go because it couldn't go anywhere
else what kind of chalk do you use
anything i can get my hands on it
doesn't take long for zinn to attract a
crowd from long time fans look at me i
always get tears in my eyes when i see
it i just love it it just makes me so
happy to first time onlookers he was
like checking out the concrete over
there the concrete over here it's like
what's going on i never seen anyone
doing this before the ground was
perfectly dry if zin isn't striking up
conversations with real people is that
what you want to be
he can often be seen talking to the
characters he's bringing to life where
are your arms i loved how he kind of
explained his personal thought and his
personal connection to it which made me
really feel like this really comes from
his heart this stuff isn't pre-planned
it's definitely from the heart and i
think he might be done
still even the most heartfelt piece of
art can get washed away with just a few
raindrops but zinn says that's all well
part of the draw famous works of art
hanging in museums gets seen by
thousands of people every day but this
you could be in among the dozens of
people who get to see this while it
exists that's pretty special is there a
lesson in all this for people
i hope so i think that's part of what
this is meant to do to celebrate the
fact that we walk through spaces on our
way to somewhere else all the time and
don't really take the time to notice
where we are and it's helped me a lot to
actually appreciate every single place
that i am for what it can do
yeah that'll do
at least until it rains
so cool james you know i was thinking
like i asked you where you shot this
because i feel like in new york city
which is a walking city yeah we're
always looking down at the sidewalks
where we see people have painted things
or on the sides of buildings but
california it's not really like la or
laguna beach is not a walking city or
maybe it is i don't know well this is in
a downtown area and lagoon beach
actually did commission this to happen
and they wanted you to pay attention to
some of the buildings uh that he was
painting on painting with chalk which i
love right because it's just so
everybody has access to chalk and i love
a guy by the name of david zinn can help
people kind of find their zen as they're
walking on their way to somewhere they
look down and they just
they ponder for a second right and enjoy
the art which well that's you people get
emotional yeah that was just so fun it's
awesome well done jamie great job